All right, so let's see if we can refine that a little bit.
We've already implemented from the last question a very naive vertex cover algorithm
that will basically check every single possible cover.
Now, let's improve that by instead of checking just one vertex v,
let's check two vertices--u and v that are still not assigned.
Now, if no two such vertices can be found, we simply output the size
of the vertex cover implied by the current assignment.
Now, there may still be vertices that are unassigned, but as we've discussed in the unit,
there's a very straightforward way to tell if this should count as 1 or 0.
If you're confused about this thing, I'd recommend going back and looking over the unit.
What I'd like you to do then is simply add un right here and it starts off as just setting u=-1
and then add un to the logic here wherever you would then normally be just manipulating v.
So you don't have to do a little bit of changing things around to check for other vertices
that are still unassigned and that's going to be a little complicated
but most of these should be relatively straightforward.
So okay. Good luck and I hope you have fun with us.